I knew Justin Timberlake very well right
after divorce and he was out of a
relationship
he was like over at my house oh and we
shared a nostalgic kiss Jessica Simpson
is totally kissing and telling about
Justin Timberlake I'm a little bit too
honest yeah you heard that right
Jessica shared a kiss with Justin after
she split from big Lachey and I thought
oh this is interesting and he took his
phone out and started typing and I was
like okay I hope that's not like another
girl like that I like stick my tongue
out too much yeah turns out Justin had
no issue with the way just kissed but he
did want to let his pal you might know
him Ryan Gosling know about it
apparently him and Ryan Gosling had a
bet on who would kiss me first when they
were 12 years old and so he texts i ryan
and said he won the bet I was like oh
okay so we don't kiss again
yeah this all went down on Wednesday
night's episode of Jimmy Kimmel Live and
if you're wondering now Jessica knows
Justin and Ryan well they go way back
she auditioned for the Mickey Mouse Club
with them but unfortunately did not get
part
throughout life we've all found our way
back to each other I see as we were in
the same circuit something even funnier
about this whole thing though jess was
totally crushing on Ryan first not JT
Ryan was the one that I was like when I
was 12 I was like this guy is so cool
and he's from Canada I don't know where
that is on the map but Justin won the
bet I don't know what to say thank you
we're hearing a lot from Jess lately
because she's gearing up to release her
memoir I mean listen I am I like I'm
already scared of like what I'm gonna
say today because I'm a loose cannon so
I somehow always make for a one-liner
here and there the book is already
proving to be a pretty personal
earlier this week she got candid about
her drinking I always had a glitter Cup
and it was always filled to the rim but
with alcohol I honestly couldn't even
tell you who got them ready
I was just dazed and confused and I just
wanted to go to sleep I didn't take them
trick-or-treating I didn't show up for
my family you know I took a picture and
I made the world think that I showed up
Jessica is also going to be releasing in
her first music in ten years it's
something that she talked to et about
back in 2015 I feel like I'm at such a
comfortable place to like open my heart
and share so much with everybody so
music makes the most sense all right
guys that's it for today for all the
latest on Jessica stick with ET until
next time I'm Katie Krause
[Music]